вітаємо і Ласкаво просимо до програми
Європа У фокусі Ми раді що ви
приєдналися до нас вони майже не мають
жодних прав і практично виключені з
суспільства життя жінок в Афганістані
стає дедалі складнішим від тоді як
таліби повернули собі владу в країні у
2021 році багато хто намагається втекти
Зора одна з тих кому це вже вдалося
разом З усією своєю музичною школою Вона
втекла на чужину і зараз живе на півночі
полі у місті брага там вона продовжує
займатися музикою тим що категорично
заборонено в її рідній
країні туга за афганістаном виконує
оркестр учасники якого були вигнані з
батьківщини тепер молоді музиканти
шукають майбутнє у
[музика]
Європі час сніданку у бразі на півночі
Португалії двоюрідні сестри Зора і
Фаріда живуть тут зі своїм дядьком
відтоді як вони втекли з Афганістану у
2021 році для цих 14тирічних дівчат
важливо протистояти забороні талібів на
музику навіть звідси з далекої
Португалії виконувати музику - Це не
злочин це мова почуттів люди
розповідають про свої почуття за
допомогою музики Я вважаю що грати
музику дуже важливо Я та людина якій
пощастило більше ніж іншим дівчатам в
Афганістані і я можу бути голосом
афганських дівчат незважаючи на свободу
здобуту у Португалії вони обидві сумують
за домом дорогою на репетицію дівчата
співають пісню рідною мовою
пушту у музичній школі інші учні уже
готуються до репетиції це головна
репетиція їхнього концертного туру
Європою який незабаром розпочнеться
португальський диригент Тіаго морейра да
Сілва вражений своїми
учнями
[музика]
їм доводилося боротися щоб потрапити до
музичної школи в їхній країні У нас тут
все зовсім інакше тож я вчуся у них
більше поважати музику для них це
справжній акт Свободи Тоді як ми
сприймаємо музику як даність Директор
афганської музичної школи був у
відпустці в Австралії коли таліби
захопили владу звідти він організував
течу своїх учнів до Португалії за режиму
талібів у школи не було
майбутнього про що мене зазвичай
запитують у ЗМІ вони питають чому таліби
забороняють музику Я кажу що іслам не
має нічого проти музики вони бояться що
музика може донести дуже важливі
повідомлення до найвіддаленіших куточків
Афганістану і музика може допомогти
народу Афганістану в національному
повстанні проти талібів
вони добре знають про Силу музики У них
є свої співаки які прославляють
бомбардування Ми попросили представників
талібану прокоментувати це але наш запит
на інтерв'ю залишився без
відповіді після репетиції Зора показує
нам фотографії із
Афганістану оце Місце де я народилася Я
сумую за снігом за всім за моєю родиною
Я дуже сумую
Іноді я плачу уночі Ніхто про це не знає
справді ніхто не знає ніхто чому ти не
плачиш коли хтось бачить Я не люблю так
робити Я не люблю засмучувати свого
дядька ти маєш бути сильною так так усе
це дуже складно витримувати 14тирічній
дівчинці трохи пізніше телефонує мама
зори Вона все ще в столиці Афганістану
кабуліві Мамо привіт Як у тебе справи
добре А ти як Мама зори розповідає про
повсякденне життя в Афганістані де зараз
навіть п'ятирічних дівчаток зобов'язують
повністю
вкриватися ми боїмося що все стане ще
суворіше і що вони дізнаються що ти досі
займаєшся
музикою
тоді нам доведеться якомога швидше
покинути
країну Зора і Фаріда добре пам'ятають
день коли вони втекли з Афганістану
їхній дядько зняв усе це на мобільний
телефон усі учні музичної школи виїхали
ми останні нам було трохи страшно в
минулому у нас було кілька виступів
нашого хору у телевізійних шоу А ви
боялися що вас впізнають і зупинять
так за допомогою португальського уряду
директор школи ахмат сармаст планує
перевести сім'ї учнів до браги
найближчими тижнями це 300 осіб великий
проект близько 150 жінок буде
врятовано жінок які втратили все в
Афганістані
з'єднуючи їх зіть тут ми також
допомагаємо їм повернути їхню
мрію цей оркестр виступав у кількох
європейських країнах зокрема у
престижному залі Вікторія Холл у Женеві
[музика]
Швейцарія давати концерт це вже протест
у розмові з нашою країною яка змушена
мовчати Це також про святкування
Перемоги афганського народу про те що ці
темні дні
минуть і саме це послання ви можете
почути у їхній
[оплески]
[музика]
музиці Так виглядає морське дно після
риболовлі із динамітом цей метод полягає
у використанні вибухівки щоб вбити або
оглушити рибу але при цьому гинуть усі
живі істоти в радіусі дії вибухівки саме
тому в європейських країнах риболовля
зди заборонена законом але вздовж
узбережжя Чорногорії цей метод досі
використовується Александр вукович
регулярно виходить у море із спортового
міста Будва на своєму човні щоб зловити
рибалок які займаються таким промислом
але Це нелегка справа оскільки ці
рибалки добре організовані а риболовля
із динамітом прибутковий
бізнес дайвер зафільмував цей вибух біля
узбережжя
Чорногорії
рибалки знову використовували Динаміт і
ось
результат вибухівка створює підводні
ударні хвилі які вбивають риби і
морських черепах а також завдають шкоди
їхній екосистемі дайвери нажахані
риболовля з динамітом ставить під
загрозу їхнє життя
теж гей перестань кидати
Динаміт ти вб'єш мене
дурень
Александр вукович оголосив війну
динамітним рибалкам разом зі своєю
асоціацією стоп нелегальній риболовлі
Він збирає відеоматеріали та докази
якими ділиться з поліцією він і сам
регулярно виходить на патрулювання із
порту
будви у певні пори року цей нелегальний
промисел значно активізується коли
великі Косяки серіол та інших риб
підходять близько до
берега це ідеальний час для динамітних
риба
Александр і його команда добре
організовані поки Александр відстежує
потенційних браконьєрів у морі члени
його команди шукають сліди їхньої
незаконної діяльності на суші вони
координують свою роботу по мобільному
телефону але Це нелегка
справа Гаразд пройдіться туди і
Перевірте чи є там
човни на жаль динамітні рибалки Теж
добре організовані У них є люди яким во
платять щоб ті повідомляли їм коли
приїжджають машини з незнайомими
номерами або коли людина здається їм
підозрілою і тоді вони втікають існує
мало даних про кількість динамітних
рибалок які орудують вздовж узбережжя
Чорногорії місцеве видання повідомило що
в пікові періоди для цього промислу
щодня використовується близько 50 кг
вибухівки Александр і його команда
публікують свої знахідки в соціальних
мережах якщо Александру вдається зловити
ти когось із браконьєрів їм може
загрожувати до трьох років
в'язниці уперед
уперед далі на північ знаходиться рідне
місто Міло іделічне Рибальське село
30тирічний чоловік розповідає що в його
родині вибухівка завжди була під рукою
бо його дідусь використовував її для
риболовлі Міло пам'ятає як виходив із
ним на риболовлю коли я був маленьким
хлопчиком 20 років тому Я ходив з
дідусем ловити кальмарів У нього завжди
був із собою Динаміт і коли він бачив
великий Косяк риби то кидав бомбу зі
скелі я покажу вам
звідки але Міло каже що не хоче мати
нічого спільного з цією сімейною
традицією він досі пам'ятає що
відбувалося коли його дідусь підривав
вибухівку Усе дуже
просто Динаміт детонує біля поверхні і
спричиняє потуж
риба оглушається і спливає на
поверхню деякі дуже великі риби йдуть на
дно ми могли виловити так від 50 до 150
кг це дуже
багато оскільки риба продається по 20
євро за кілограм це хороші гроші для
рибалок обговорює цю проблему із
політиками у міністерстві сільського
господарства він зустрічається з
керівницею Департаменту рибного
господарства але в її відповідях немає
конкретики ми розробляємо новий закон
про морське рибальство і кримінальні
положення наш
пріоритет Вони мають бути суворішими А
вині мають понести відповідне
покарання проблема в тому що хоч
риболовля з вибухівкою карається законом
насправді не було винес
жодного обвинувального вироку Александр
каже що поліції не вистачає ресурсів для
забезпечення дотримання цього закону як
тільки ця країна скаже досить динамітним
рибалкам ця проблема вирішиться протягом
місяця але Наразі це малоймовірно поки
не відбудуться реальні зміни рибалки з
динамітом у цьому раю відпочинку
ймовірно продовжуватимуть свій промисел
А разом з тим і руйнування підводних
екосистем унаслідок кліматичних змін
літо в Європі стає дедалі спекотнішим і
сухішим а зокрема ій у горах альпухара
на півдні Іспанії фермерам тут
доводиться застосовувати свої ноухау щоб
забезпечити зрошення своїх полів і для
таких людей як пако Перес таке ноухау -
це мудрість яка Сягає своїм корінням ще
до часів древніх маврів вони вторглися в
Іспанію понад 1300 років тому і
побудували в цьому регіоні зрошувальні
канали які донині приносять велику
користь багатьом пакопе 95 років але він
і досі простягає руку допомоги коли це
[музика]
потрібно Навряд чи хтось у його селі
знає цю стару іригаційну систему так
добре як
він бачити воду в каналах завжди було
для мене найбільшим
задоволенням ми обробляли нею наші поля
ми жили завдяки цим
каналам
[музика]
у VI столітті маври побудували складну
мережу каналів у горах регіону альпухара
на півдні Іспанії ці іригаційні канави
використовують І донині пако та його син
Антоніо використовую цю систему для
поливу своїх плантацій перцю Тож вони
отримують вигоду від цієї спадщини
маврів ця система яку вони нам залишили
дуже важлива хоча будували зрошувані
канали та араби довели їх до
досконалості але багато з цих канав не
використовувалися роками тому вони
відновлюють їх у співпраці із археологом
Хосе Марія Мартіном
сівантосом Він каже що користь від них
виходить далеко за межі сільського
господарства
старі канал як цей дуже важливий для
навколишнього середовища вони створюють
життя частина води просочується в Зем і
потрапляє
нижче Таким чином ця система сприяє
більшому
біорізноманіттю мережа каналів запобігає
занадто швидкому стіканню води води яка
стає все більш дефіцитною пако каже що
вже ніхто не може заперечувати факт
кліматичних
змін у моєму селі не було снігу вже 18
років раніше нам завжди доводилося
змітати сніг із плоских дахів на
вулицю іноді сніг міг лежати 15 днів 20
днів чи місяць тепер ці часи в
минулому водосховище відображають гостру
нестачу води і тим не менш Іспанія
вирощує все більше і більше тропічних
фруктів таких як манго і авокадо які
потребують багато води тому фермери все
більше покладаються на автоматизовані
Системи які доставляють воду до кожної
окремої рослини крапля за
краплею сільськогосподарський інженер
Едуардо мальдонадо каже що старі канали
вже непридатні для використання оскільки
вода просочується і випаровується Під
час
транспортування за крапельним зрошенням
майбутнєм воно набагато ефективніше і
може бути впроваджене на всіх типах
господарство воно дозволяє економити від
40 до 6
води пако та Антоніо не поділяють таку
думку вони продовжують поливати свої
поля водою зі зрошувальних каналів
маврів але визнають Що це невигідно для
великих фермерських
господарств у наш час одній людині
доводиться робити багато справ
одночасно ось справжня причина чому вони
переходять на автоматизоване крапельне
зрошення а не Тому що воно краще
археологи вважають іригаційні канави
маврів більш актуальними ніж
будь-коли тому Вони намагаються
перейняти досвід у старших мешканців сіл
альпухари ці знання
забуваються якщо ми подивимося на
ефективність з декількох точок Зоро а
також на переваги для довкілля то ці
системи набагато
ефективніші особливо враховуючи нинішні
Кліматичні
зміни але традиційних фермерів які
використовують старі канали стає все
менше і
менше це ускладнює збереження спадщини
маврів сучасна молодь нічого про це не
знає колись старі люди поступалися
місцем
молоді а сьогодні у свої 95 років я досі
приходжу на роботу на ці
канали Але у порівнянні з більш ніж
тисячолітніми іригаційними каналами
маврів він зовсім молодий тому для паку
і таких як він не може бути мови про те
щоб
здатися протягом багатьох років
Фінляндія і Росія були переважно
дружніми сусідами для росіян відкриті
кордони Тут були воротами до заходу а
для Фінляндії великий російський сусід
був важливим і близьким ринком збуту але
все суттєво змінилося в тому числі і в
прикордонній
лапенранці війна в Україні повністю
змінила політичний клімат Фінляндії і
тепер фінські політики кажуть що Росія
зовсім не такий сусід яким вони її
вважали капітан ярі хемельянен прийшов
до такого ж висновку він знає цей
прикордонний регіон майже 50 років і
ніколи раніше не був свідком такої кризи
Якщо ви поїдете до столиці Норвегії Осло
то зможете побачити всесвітньо відому
картину крик Едварда мунка картину яка
коштує мільйони і дуже надійно
охороняється очевидно що торкатися її
суворо
заборонено але поїдьте в Амстердам і ви
отримаєте ма майже діаметрально
протилежний дозвід тут копія картини
монка та безліч інших шедеврів мистецтва
зібрані в одному місці і в цій галереї
ви можете підійти до витворів мистецтва
настільки близько наскільки
захочете А на сьогодні це все дякуємо за
перегляд Бережіть себе і до зустрічі за
тиждень у Ново пу програми Європа У
[музика]
фокусі